when we're racing it's it's head-to-head
but at the same time you're battling the
clock they say that if you're not
crashing you're not flying when you have
a bunch of pilots that are all at the
top tier they're running so tight next
to each other that at MIT as are kind of
common yeah I crashed in the finals to
which everyone had crashed out already
and it was just my pretty much my
competition to win and nerves got to me
and I crashed out the drones that were
racing our high-performance craft and
they're they're specifically meant for
racing we actually maintain an entire
fleet of drones so we have about 100
that we bring from the event to event
maintained by drone technicians
absolutely I'm taking my wrist I don't
have to fix it at the end of the day I'm
flying that thing and I've had a hundred
percent the whole time whatever happens
happens
one of the things that's interesting to
watch as we launch the league is that
there are some really talented pilots
but they've never been tested in a
competition format if you if you're
concerned with doing backflips and
making it look pretty you're not
concerned with being fast when it comes
to racing you just want to finish the
race welcome to level 1 Miami the first
race of the 2016 season the nerves were
higher than any other race I've ever
been in when we see people get the most
excited about drone racing content it's
that proximity flight it's drones flying
through a space you guys are the
walk-around and think what would be like
to fly through this at a high speed and
the winner can't incredibly say they're
the best pilot in the world